yassine est avec nous a prédit son
courrier le maire de villejuif tu en as
quand même bien crever les polémiques
c'est comme ça va le public déjà scellé
[Applaudissements]
vous prenez ça va le public j'irai quoi
il lui
j'y vais dans le public des années les
polémiques c'est comme les équipes de
foot parfois c'est d'un bon niveau et
parfois non et hier mon cher syrie les
polémiques
c'était le fc gueugnon des polémiques la
montre d'eric na waie alors ça vous avez
vu ça sans rigoler c'est honteux et
critiqué pour être apparu sur une photo
en train de coller une affiche avec une
montre et des boutons de manchette de
luxe
alors ça regardez la montre la montre
qu'il portait ce jour là était
visiblement une brique et ça coûterait
un peu plus de 10000 euros
ah oui alors ça fait ça c'est une
polémique je connais d'abri des alors
moi ça me choque absolument pas étant
fils de ménage de femme de ménage comme
dupont moretti je revendique le droit de
montrer son oseille quand on en assure
que ce soit dans les mondes comme le
ministre dans les chaussures comme
guillaume genton alors cyril et comme tu
n'aimes pas souffler sur les braises au
détail hier tu as essayé d'éteindre la
polémique avec élégance et qu'est ce que
tu as fait ben oui c'est vrai j'ai tout
chez lui commence à regarder
bassila une patek philippe chronographe
calendrier puisque on a revu ces photos
il a enrôlé kseur perpétuelle voilà ils
adorent les montres et la droite j
relationnel une autre marque privée une
fps journée chronomètre souverain je
crois que c'était un journal mais voilà
voilà donc on est à deux doigts de
montrer ses slips ça t'amuse de balancer
comme ça cyril moi aussi je peux le
faire moi aussi j'ai fait mon enquête
mon cher cyril j'ai retrouvé des choses
quitte appartiennent que tu aurais voulu
cacher regard des voisins par exemple ta
raquette de paddle en or manquée coûte
350 mille euros ensuite la petite maison
pour seine saint denis on regarde une
valeur de 300 fois le budget du
département 150 chambres 95 salle de
bain une salle de sport où nous n'allons
pas et regardez même le château vue du
ciel regarder ses 8
les chroniqueurs évidemment collègues
formidable j'ai retrouvé des trucs à
vous aussi chez bernard montiel une
cabine de bronzage intégral d'une valeur
de 60 mille euros chez isabelle morini
bosc collection de 300 lui alors que lui
a offert son premier mari louis 11 des
valeurs de 300 louis d'or et enfin chez
gilles verdez regarder une collection de
john à bannalec yannick passe ses
week-ends fait hier tu as passé
tu as parlé aussi de cette prouesse
technologique incroyable
on n'avait pas vu ça d'intel futurisme
depuis l'arrivée du mythe minitel
regarder
nous sommes
c'est une première c'est impressionnant
franchement bravo bravo quel mytho
exceptionnelle en moi je trouve que ça
mérite de retenter l'expérience est très
décalé nous a livré attention c'est le
moment technologique dans la chronique
ou civile comme tu le vois c'est
vraiment une technologie très avancée
star wars est en train de rougir je suis
au milieu d'intervilles j'ai fait un
bisou à la vachette elle n'a rien senti
et je voulais faire un gros kick ou à
tous les chroniqueurs de tpm p bisous
bisous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je vois déjà la blague pour dire
que ce n'est pas un nom logram vu mon
poids 7 1 kg
mais c'est pas plus ridicule que celui
de kenji que je salue pour finir cyril
je sais que dans cette émission on parle
souvent des membres du gouvernement les
reçoit et à un an de la présidentielle
j'ai décidé d'apporter l'expertisé
vraiment précise de la chaîne arte sur
le gouvernement français voici le théma
d'arte et sur le gouvernement
je fouine ce gouvernement heaslip by
jean castex isr clôture le dow mais josh
qu'ovide like home the love dealer
frustrante like francis lalanne des dix
kind of shit
yann castex apte à une lustig coupe à
lens pour fill in das grosse vadrouille
vernaz acte 1 meine farhad marine farhad
lustig französisch bahdja castex is not
the rust service au ministère on my god
elles font tiennent vaille que marlène
schiappa or marlène schiappa chichi the
big ministre au ministre comme nationaux
neglect nénesse marlène je sais pas marc
les niches weissenstein d'autres choses
par vagues
neeman vice warum sitariste à la taupe
scientist avril christine of the watch
it rock
hélas oui parce que les mises line main
ils vont s'atténuer avec les femmes
voilées my friends au professeur ben may
bowles from the university of war that
tell me something very few things et
pouf the theory of the show ma is
something saint paul machy tox mon sens
people have it schwab
le catésis graphique vermeille twisting
monchy tox mort french people by herring
raid a une odeur ministère des lloyd
pression du beurre insiste gérald à
mannheim darmanin istace sarkozy phone
pas-de-calais vire canard sarko ch'tis
what is crazy with the man with cordes
also moussa moussa et tout guen pas à
cannes femme n'ose africa so2 of what i
explain big love of the big sommes en
deuil à une élite et béton et because it
offers copa friends in front of navarro
robot
hop au mali bling ce ministère est hans
michel blanquer a donc go to live bottes
ami fred au fusain michel bouquet et
remember be1 qu'elle fest le qu'attiser
les anglais avec des vagues de départ de
ministres éducation petit touristique
abonde joggeuse dans le cas de gale chez
eux
je suis dans le quizz de sorties
scolaires peco 0 jobs aux mondiaux job
in the world of his libye ym weill est
restée n'a bien d'autres cultures et
restera au ring here is strong al saoud
caractère ao inspector d'eric if you
asked if the french government can be
west high say yes you will see in one
here
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et mort d'hommes sahraoui